joining us now with more louisiana
senator john kennedy senator i'll let
you jump right into this discussion uh
all of these problems that we're
discussing here are preventable and
they're all about to get worse because
if we fire the health care workers and
the cops and the firemen and the other
medical workers in our military uh i
hate to think what that impact will be
on the economy
sean this is certainly about more than
uh
than treadmills
if you have a pulse
and a marginal desire for a better life
you know that president biden is in
trouble
and therefore america's in trouble
measured any way you want the debacle in
afghanistan which has
emboldened russia and china and iran
the unbridled inflation
gas prices
open borders
crime
a justice department that thinks parents
are dangerous domestic terrorists
a treasury department that wants access
to the checking account
of every american who has a job no no
wonder
the american people are so angry there
it's no wonder that so many americans
um
think that this administration doesn't
care about them or their lives or their
future
now
i say this with respect with all the
respect i can muster
but my advice to the president is this
mr president you've just got to try
harder not to suck
and the best way to do that in my
opinion
is stop worrying so much about the
wokers
you're never going to make them happy
they hyperventilate on their yoga mats
at the slightest provocation you're
never going to make them happy stop
worrying about the wokers
and start worrying about america's
workers and i'm talking about the people
who get up every day and go to work and
obey the law and pay their taxes and try
to do the right thing by their kids
they made america great ordinary people
doing extraordinary things and we're not
going to get this country back on track
and the president's not going to be more
popular with the american people until
he stops worrying about wokers and
starts worrying about workers and that's
to me is what it's all about
you know something
i don't think he's capable of it senator
i'm not even sure if he knows what day
of the week it is and i don't say that
flippantly i say it with sadness and i
think he agrees with the workers we have
a minute left
well then what the president's going to
have to do i i don't know if that's
accurate or not i'm not saying it's
wrong i'm not saying it's right the
president then is going to have to
replace some of the people around him
who seem to be obsessed
with trying to make
the the left of lenin neo socialist
bolsheviks happy but wait i mean senator
senator he signed the bernie biden
manifesto didn't he
oh i'm not i'm not excusing the
president he's ultimately responsible
but but
but senator sanders senator bernie
sanders
um he tested negative for president
i mean the american people didn't elect
him
they they elected joe biden
and joe biden basically said look i will
govern from the middle i'll be the
second coming of of barack obama
maybe a little left of middle
instead he's been the second cousin of
bernie sanders and his entire
administration
is owned lock stock and barrel by the
walkers
and they're not america hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else